[Música]
retomamos la economía en directo américa
con jorge hurtado jorge los problemas en
la cadena de suministros hasta cuando
hasta el próximo año así lo dijo el
secretario de transporte de eeuu hasta
la pandemia o en otras la pandemia la
demanda de bienes y servicios vive un
acelerado crecimiento al que los
fabricantes y transportistas no han sido
capaces de dar respuestas lo que ha
generado un cuello de botella a esto se
le suman las interrupciones de los
horarios relacionados con la pandemia y
la escasez de trabajadores portuarios
ejemplo de ello raúl son los puertos de
los ángeles y long beach en eeuu que
viven en una situación de colapso con
largas filas de enormes cargueros
navegando frente a los muelles a la
espera de poder atracar y descargar sus
mercancías en esos puertos raúl ingrese
el 40 por ciento de todos los productos
importados en ese país se teme que los
retrasos afecten las ventas navideñas un
informe de financial times revela que el
costo de flete se ha disparado el precio
global promedio de envío de un
contenedor de 40 pies llega a los 10 mil
dólares tres veces más alto a inicios de
año y diez veces más que los niveles
previos a la pandemia
sobre cómo vería mi amiga jennifer lópez
el abastecimiento para cuando en china
ahora vamos donde ya se brindaron datos
oficiales de la economía de ese país así
es y los datos no son tan alentadores
como esperaban hace dos meses allí los
problemas de la crisis de suministro de
energía y la deuda el sector
inmobiliario
especialmente la empresa de habrán
ralentizaron la economía en el tercer
trimestre según los reportes oficiales
el producto interno bruto creció 4,9 por
ciento en comparación con el mismo
período del año anterior aunque el gasto
de los consumidores se recuperó tras los
rebrotes de la variante delta de agosto
pasado la producción industrial sufrió
un gran revés en septiembre por los
cortes de energía debido a los problemas
de suministro de carbón hay que destacar
que el carbón es la principal fuente de
energía en china así como los altos
precios de ese material que obligó a las
autoridades a racionar la en importantes
zonas de producción las autoridades
aceptaron también un escenario complejo
escuchemos que dijeron
en términos generales en la economía
nacional mantuvo el impulso de
recuperación en los tres primeros
trimestres sin embargo debemos señalar
que las incertidumbres del entorno
internacional actual están aumentando y
la economía nacional la recuperación
sigue siendo inestable y desigual google
y empieza con el primer pago de su deuda
primero los indicadores así en los
principales índices de wall street abren
a la baja a medida que se desacelera el
crecimiento económico en china en asia
los mercados ahorraron mixto este inicio
de semana por el optimismo de la
reapertura tras la pandemia en europa
las bolsas cayeron luego de los datos
negativos en china korea ahora cambiamos
de tema vamos ahora a honduras porque se
inauguró un aeropuerto así que se trata
del aeropuerto internacional palmerola
en comayagua que comparte espacio con
una base militar estadounidense y que
busca reemplazar el aeropuerto toncontín
que está en el centro de tegucigalpa y
es considerado uno de los más peligrosos
del mundo el nuevo aeropuerto comenzará
a operar el próximo mes con una pista de
2800 metros siete mangas y el edificio
de la terminal y 9.000 metros cuadrados
el aeropuerto raúl tuvo una inversión
que supera los 235 millones de dólares
de los cuales españa aportó 53 millones
como parte de un programa de
reconversión de deuda con honduras de
esta forma hondura reemplaza al antiguo
aeropuerto de calificado entre los más
peligrosos del mundo por organismos
internacionales de aeronáutica y la
cifra del día jorge cuál es la cifra del
día 24.1 millones de dólares costo a
netflix el especial de comedia the days
apple the closer la compañía recibió
muchas críticas tras el estreno de este
especial del comediante de s&p él debido
a sus comentarios sobre las personas
transgénero puede ser jorge gracias por
toda la información gracias por pagar a
todas las deudas lo que nos daría en la
economía nos vemos mañana con más
información vámonos ahora directo esta
pared que parece nos fuimos a manos
[Música]